all right we are live on the youtube i'm
still dave rubin and we've got another
friday roundtable extravaganza for you
today we're talking about how cobit has
impacted our children our relationships
and possibly most importantly our mental
health joining me to discuss our author
of the upcoming book dear hartley
thoughts on character kindness and
building a brighter world jedediah bila
i've got the book right here host of the
washington examiner newsmaker series
alicia krauss and author of the end of
gender debunking the myths about sex and
identity in our society dr debra soh
ladies welcome to the reuben report
hi
i have never had an all-female panel
before i'm i'm slightly freaking out are
you guys going to take it easy on me
today
yeah no
absolutely not i don't know if you're
prepared for this dave i'm i'm gonna be
honest i'm gonna come out right out of
the gate and say i don't know if you're
ready
i am definitely not prepared i feel like
i feel like megan mccain on the view
which jedediah you know a little
something about
uh all right so let's let's jump in
because there's a whole bunch of stuff i
want to talk to you guys about and i
thought at the end of this week it was
so nutty as always i didn't want to do
just like pure like recap political
nonsense i want to talk about the human
part of some of this stuff so alicia i
want to start with you uh just talk
about the covid situation masks and
vaccines related to kids you have you
have young kids you take them out and
about here in crazy los angeles uh how
old are your kids again and how's it
going just having kids in the mix in in
the midst of this whole thing
i actually have to say having kids in
the mix of this is seems more difficult
now in this like post half locked down
mandate type thing than it was even an
early coven we're blessed to have a yard
and a pool we've been social since april
of 2020 hosting play dates and going
places and doing things and it seemed
easier back then now it's much more
difficult uh i do take my girls all over
los angeles and we i do not mask them
unless we're getting on an airplane and
absolutely have to uh my two-year-old
has never been asked to be masked on a
plane which is i'm kind of glad i
haven't had an incident with a cairn
flight attendant yet yet uh and it's
hard i think you know
my kids are very social uh i'm
homeschooling i tell people i'm a
massive fan of school choice as you know
but i wanted i wanted to be able to
choose whether or not to homeschool and
i felt like this year i was kind of
forced to homeschool because i wasn't
going to send my second grader to school
to be in a mask all day in an
environment where she would be totally
fine and if she did get covered it'd be
completely traceable unlike you know the
rolling stones at so far stadium the
other night where masks were not
enforced and people were just like
flashing their phones to get in
pretending like they had a vaccine card
and lord knows i mean i love how the
media is such a double standard of
churches john mcarthur super spreader
rolling stones totes okay
it's hard it's really hard on kids and
i'm grateful that they have us uh but
there are lots of kids even with two
incredible parents that are experiencing
anxiety emotional educational
communicative delays and and my kids are
some of those
jediah hartley's on the cover of the
book so how's he doing in the midst of
all of this and actually i'm not even
totally sure where are you that that'll
give a little context yeah so i went i'm
in new york city of all places leaving
though leaving because i cannot justify
raising a child in this this bad
dystopian novel that's unfolding here
but it's been pretty hard for him i mean
hartley is almost two years old he was
about four and a half months old when
covert really hit stride in new york
city uh he actually had covid um his
only symptom was eczema he was fine he
laughed through the whole thing was it
was a big inspiration to everyone in the
house at the time
but um it was really challenging because
kids learn from other kids and you know
i had the experience of having taught
kids for a really long time i taught you
know ages two straight through college
so i know that children need to be
around other children i know that these
masks are incredibly detrimental because
their development their behavioral
skills they learn so much by reading
emotions on people's faces and for a
very long time i couldn't get him to
have any contact with children we don't
have a lot of family here we don't have
a lot of little kids in our family so i
was looking forward to mommy and me this
or daddy and me that and just having his
development go like any other kid and it
was impossible even upon leaving
manhattan it was still impossible places
were closed and then you know if you did
get to go to a place even though the
kids weren't masked because he was too
small for that luckily the adults were
masked and that bothered me a lot too
because he was scared of people he
developed fears about people
you know you take him to a
pediatrician's office and the
pediatrician of mass i don't want that
to be what he holds on to
so it was incredibly challenging um and
you know it has led up a little bit
recently um but but you know just
watching him go through that there were
some things that he was a little bit
late to the party on in terms of
learning because he couldn't see other
kids and once i could get him with those
kids it made such it was like
instantaneous pickup and i was like wow
this child has really been missing out
um so watching what's unfolded truly on
these airplanes with these masked
children i mean this child abuse is
actively happening in many of these
facilities for a disease that 99.99
plus
of children survive so at some point as
a society it is incumbent upon us to say
enough and not just say enough but fight
back yeah and i've said it a million
times just to reiterate your point but
the latest cdc numbers that we could
pull off their own website the morbidity
for children under 18 years old 0.002
percent about 500 kids and also there's
a lot of evidence that some of that had
all sorts of other co-morbidities and
some of them shouldn't have counted and
a whole bunch of other stuff uh deborah
to both of the ladies point
psychologically what we are doing to a
entire generation of children
four-year-olds that we're keeping in
masks they're not reading facial cues
they're not seeing their friends they're
spending more time on tick tock on ipads
and everything else
what do you think this is going to do to
this mass
group of young people that are i agree
with jedediah that are being abused
basically
i mean i'm i'm really concerned about
this i want to say i don't do clinical
work anymore and so i don't work with
kids but i would say i mean you don't
need to look at the research literature
to know that
this i mean it's such a critical time in
their lives in terms of
something as simple as interacting with
their friends
these mandates like masks mask the mass
mandates and also social distancing i
understand that it's coming from a place
in some cases of people being concerned
about these children and wanting to
protect them but like you said the risk
of children contracting covet is so low
and i really feel in some ways it's just
parental anxieties that are being
justified or being
encouraged instead of pushed back on
which it's not ultimately going to be
good for these kids so in terms of say
something like
socio-emotional
development learning emotions reading
motions and
also being able to
adequately
communicate how someone is a child is
feeling
for children especially who say have a
predisposition towards being on the
autism spectrum so i don't think these
mandates will cause a child to have
autism but i i do worry what the
implications will be because for a child
who is on the autism spectrum they have
difficulties expressing themselves
difficulties with social reciprocity so
difficulties also in terms of reading
other people's perspectives
explaining their own feelings and
emotions and so i i don't think this is
going to be good for their development
either
steve can i just just add one thing is
because we often talk about small
children but also let's not forget those
adolescents that missed graduations that
missed you know
their sweet 16s that missed these
monumental events in their lives that
also shape them i mean they're learning
how to interact with members of the
opposite sex they're they're learning a
lot about themselves through
self-discovery through
that time in their lives and now they're
being deprived of that so you know and
they're also absorbing all of the
anxiety in their households you know
when you're a 16 year old and you're
hearing conversations constantly about
how mommy or daddy's going to lose their
job because they're there's now a
vaccine mandate that they have a medical
exemption to and suddenly that's you
know the company's saying it doesn't
count and now finances are tight i mean
they have absorbed the weight of things
that are far greater than what's been
just inflicted upon them in terms of
masks or missing school although those
things are grave it goes way deeper than
that and what types of skills have these
kids now
not develop properly because we
prevented them from being in regular
normal settings
to that point i mean are you shocked at
how few parents actually push back on
this stuff i mean even this morning now
cdc is trying to push that there will be
vaccine mandates for kids as young as
five years old and you know then they'll
push it beyond that and it's like this
stuff could not have possibly been
tested properly we know that the
pharmaceutical companies aren't even
liable legally if something goes wrong
also kids just don't need it if you look
at the statistics there is no reason to
give my four-year-old next year when she
turns five a covid vaccine for something
that she's likely already had and
something that she has a great
survivability for because thank god she
has no underlying symptoms i just think
it's ridiculous kids there's been an
increase in rsv which is much more
deadly to my two-year-old than
jedediah's little boy than kovid
nobody's talking about that oh maybe
because kids were kept away from other
children and their immune immune systems
weren't able to be built up over the
last year and a half and uh beyond that
the flu is more deadly to kids you're
more likely to be improperly buckling
your child in a five-point car seat
harness but the schools and the churches
and the health departments in los
angeles county aren't checking every
single parent with a kid under the age
of eight years old so the hypocrisy here
and the lack of science and the leaning
into the fear is what really concerns me
and and i have a concern i've been
saying this a lot i feel like i'm
repeating myself a part of me is very
glad that my eight-year-old when a
sunday school teacher told her that she
needed to put on a mask was like i'm
sorry you can't tell me what to put on
my body talk to my mom i was like yes
but then the other part of me is
concerned that these children have a
distrust in people that they're supposed
to have a level of respect for and
authority and i'm afraid maybe this
generation might go to the anarchical
side and they want to blow everything up
and i'm okay with you know some of the
systems being taken down as a small
government conservative but i'm
concerned in 20 30 40 years but that
means not only for my daughters but my
granddaughters one day so basically your
daughter said my body my choice which
now makes her as an eight-year-old a
right-wing maniac deborah can you talk a
little bit from a psychological
perspective just about about this fear
issue
that we're talking about not only that
the kids won't be able to read adults
and read other
children in terms of emotions but the
fear related to the parents because i
know a ton of people right now that are
completely afraid to say what they think
whether it's vaccine related government
related cancer culture related that
we're all walking around in this like
very strange state of constant fear or
not all of us but but many of us
yeah and to at least this point also
with the the science and the science
denial that's happening the suppression
of science and the distortion of science
i find that really concerning as well as
a broader theme because
public trust in in health messaging and
the dissemination of this information it
should not be political but it has
become political and i i totally
understand why people are so skeptical
now because once you sense that there's
a particular narrative and that people
are lying to you about information that
should be objective well i understand
why people lose all trust and say well
i'm not going to listen to anything that
these organizations or these experts are
saying because they lied about this one
thing they're not admitting that they
lied about it and so what else are they
potentially lying about so with regard
to your your point about anxiety and
fear i mean
in terms of the mental health effects i
would say of the last 18 months to two
years
i think it's devastating i mean for me
myself i've been really lucky i've been
very healthy but i i look around at
people i know and you know you look at
just overwhelmingly people seem to
really be struggling with depression
anxiety in some cases suicidal ideation
substance use problems and these are
adults so you can only imagine what it's
going to be like for children who are
going through this who may not have the
vocabulary to express necessarily how
they're feeling but i would also say for
with with regard to say cancer culture
and the fact that people are actually
losing their livelihoods over this and
over the politicization of this actually
makes me very angry because that should
not be happening at all i think whatever
people choose to do with their own
bodies is their business and whose
business is it for them to come in and
say you have to do this you're they're
essentially being people are being
coerced actually being course now
because if you can't work what what can
you do
yeah jedediah are you shocked how
quickly the adults all kind of failed
like that's what it seems like to me
that the the adult class the people that
are basically between 35 and 60 just
pretty much everybody just was like yeah
we'll just do whatever you want just
keep you know thank you sir may i have
another
yeah i think it's concerning it's deeply
concerning that so many people are
comfortable being told what to do
that they're comfortable telling other
people what to do and that they're also
comfortable with the knowledge that
there are some people that have a vested
interest in this pandemic not ending
they have a financial interest in that
they have a political interest in that
and those fear tactics enable a lot of
politicians to gain and maintain a lot
of power so
really this only changes when people say
i'm not doing it when they say i don't
care if you fire me when they say i'll
pull my kid out of school and i'll
figure something else out that's when
this changes and i think when it comes
to the medical community i have heard
from hundreds and i'm not exaggerating
hundreds of doctors who are appalled by
what went down with respect to natural
immunity they have spent their whole
lives basing their careers on actual
science when you come out and you're now
saying that a bunch of kids who already
are not in a high risk bracket
by a long shot now are going to be
vaccinated and you know that's going to
come down to a mandate that's going to
happen in schools let's just say it now
and those kids are haven't even been
tested for natural immunity to see if
they don't need it i mean this is not
about science when you have people with
medical exemptions in companies that
signed letters from their doctors that
are being ignored this is not about
health so people need to wake up and
they need to wake up fast you have
people that have fled communist regimes
showing up at rallies and saying we are
trying to warn you that when you know
the thing is dave when you don't have
your health
you you there's nothing else right if
you're sitting and you're unhealthy
nothing else matters and it's it's
shocking to me that people don't trust
their own gut and are so comfortable
living listening to a bureaucrat be it a
political bureaucrat a corporate
bureaucrat whatever it may be make your
voices heard and if you're not willing
to speak up for yourself speak up for
your children and if you're not willing
to speak up for your children speak up
for your country for heaven's sake
because this is not what a free society
looks like yeah you know i had an
illegal little dinner thing last night
and a couple people here and it was a
girl who i hadn't met before was brought
by a friend and she was saying that she
grew up in soviet russia her parents uh
are here now and all they've been
talking about for the last year is how
this is exactly what it felt like over
there wait dinners are illegal
was it illegal i'm not even sure what
i'm doing anymore i never leave so i
don't know
i've been having legal dinner parties
and barbecues and play dates i know you
have to stay in your bunker permanently
yeah i know i know well we'll talk about
florida later uh alicia um the media
side of this which jedidiah is sort of
hitting that we just don't we don't
trust anybody anymore and it seems to me
like all you know i don't have cable
anymore but when i do see clips out of
cnn and msnbc
it's like they should be playing the
looney tunes theme in the back because
it's just
it's just utter nonsense but this is a
bad idea actually dave no trust me it
works and also when keith olbermann is
standing on his porch above central park
when he's doing his rants you play the
looney tunes theme song to that
that's perfect
but that that we don't trust our media
anymore bit of a problem right
it's a major problem and they're
completely by the way the distrust in
media was happening i was giving
speeches in 2019 about distress and
media and how that's bad for american
society as a whole because we should be
able to tune in and watch someone
whether it's you or ben shapiro or even
jake tapper on cnn and think this guy's
going to be delivering me the facts and
the truth except unfortunately and when
it comes to a lot of mainstream all of
the mainstream media outlets i would
argue that is not the case anymore and
so you have people i think that are then
turning to the extreme conspiracy
theories
like one thing that i saw this week
three different friends sent me from the
osho website saying that they are not
going to have employers report side
effects to the covid vaccine because the
osha is encouraging all employers and
all employees to get the vaccine and
maybe they'll reassess that next year
when i saw this screenshot i was like
this has to be fake this has to be from
some anti-vaxxer on instagram nope went
to the website myself and it's there but
the media isn't going to report on it
and this is the type of truths all it
takes is a truth in a conspiracy theory
to feed the conspiracy and the
mainstream media is 1 000
complicit in this and they are
increasing the divide in the united
but in states it is them and they need
to look in the mirror also you're seeing
the power of not just big media but the
collusion between big media big tech
big hollywood bit now big pharma i mean
i look sometimes and i see i i'm on you
know twitter and i'm like are these ads
from pharmaceuticals and and and their
news headlines coming from supposed news
organizations and it's just you know
this isn't about how you personally or i
personally feel about vaccines this is
about you know they're trying to just
push a certain way of life on people we
live in the united states of america
this is supposed to be you know the land
of the free where is it i mean you now
people say well you have the option you
don't have to get the back seat really
well i didn't know that that was
supposed to come with a little note that
said if you decide that for yourself
because you've had it or you have
another health condition or maybe you
just don't want the vaccine and you want
to incur that risk on to yourself you
also have to say i'll never work again
or i'll be out of a job and won't be
able to feed my family no i'm sorry that
is not the workings of a free society
that is the way tyranny operates and you
see it alive and well in places like los
angeles and new york city where people
now have to answer to bill de blasio not
their own doctors not their own doctors
bill de blasio about what they should do
with their health tomorrow if they want
to eat a sandwich in a restaurant this
is atrocious what's going on and people
need to wake up jedi ironically i was in
new york city a couple weeks ago and
it's a hell of a lot better than la that
may be hard for you to believe but it is
it is way more open there's way more
people out there are way more people not
wearing masks and everything else debra
at a psychological uh perspective
we were all taught when we were growing
up stand up to the bullies say what you
think be different
none of that exists anymore that's a
problem
well i think even though we were taught
to stand up to the bullies in terms of
say
social psychology and group behavior
people tend not to want to be ostracized
by their peers or by society because
from an evolutionary perspective if you
are get kicked out of the group you're
left to fend for your own for yourself
and we do see that with people who do
get canceled i think some of us keep
going regardless you know as you and i
talked about last week just
it doesn't matter how they're going to
try and ostracize us or how they're
going to try and punish us we're going
to keep going but i don't think everyone
is necessarily like that and i think for
a lot of people
that the potential risk of speaking up
is really terrifying and they would they
have an easier time just going about
their lives i think also if you have a
family of a mortgage i understand why
there may be different pressures at play
but i i would really advocate for
anybody you know now is the time to do
it because it's only going to get worse
and
the fact i don't even think that most
people are on board with what's
happening i actually think most people
are really skeptical they're really
uncomfortable but they're afraid because
there is that aspect of being shamed
being called a conspiracy theorist being
called a crazy person people don't don't
want that and they're making it
especially hard for us to find each
other because it is so seen as so
socially and acceptable to have these
views but to definitely i mean i'm sure
your audience already already knows this
but anyone watching you're not alone in
the way that you feel and i can only
imagine how isolating it must be to to
think that unfortunately yeah i mean i
agree with you so much there debra i
think that this is where jedediah's
point about how big tech is working with
big pharma and liberals in power to
suppress the voices that are really
representing average americans that go
to social media and they see their
favorite celebrity or their favorite
talking head or their favorite you know
late night tv host telling them that
they are crazy if they are anti-mandate
or they are insane if they're
anti-teacher and they don't want their
kids masked at school but they truly are
not they're not alone and i would say to
anyone that's watching that feels alone
we're not the only ones that agree with
you obviously we're all sticking our
necks out there because you know it's a
part of our job and i joke that i've dug
my political grave so i might as well
lie in it but there are a lot of moms
out there there are a lot of dads
there's a lot of small business owners
there's a lot of people on boards of
corporations that agree with you and we
need your voices to rise up or this
ain't going to stop jedidiah as someone
that was on the view and and you know
arguing
all sorts of perspectives all the time
and you know unfortunately in my humble
opinion the view the view ain't what it
was say 20 years ago uh when when
barbara first started when it really was
something special i think um
the fact that we can't seem to do any of
this publicly you know we walk you know
we'll have people walking off stage if
someone comes on with a viewpoint they
don't like or cutting to commercial or
yelling at people even the very people
who are supposed to enable some level of
conversation don't seem to be doing it
very well right now yeah well that's a
reflection of a coddled society that's a
reflection of you know college campuses
where you have safe spaces and you're
triggered if someone dares to say
something that you disagree with and you
are told that it's okay to feel that way
yes you know you're supposed to be in a
protected space no that's not real life
and it's going to be incumbent upon
parents to teach their children
otherwise it's going to be an incumbent
upon parents to say you know what you're
going to enter rooms full of people that
disagree with you stand up for what you
believe in listen carefully if your mind
gets changed admit to it be an honest
person in those exchanges and be
passionate about what you believe so a
lot of it's going to come down to family
it's going to come down to community and
it's going to come down to reversing
unfortunately you send your kids to
college oftentimes and i've taught in
college classrooms as well and that's
where brains go to rot i know that's
controversial but it's true you enter
that those spaces and suddenly you are
inculcated with this is the way you're
supposed to see the world and if you
don't see it that way there will be
consequences grade wise you will be
ostracized you'll have to you know go
and all of a sudden you're part of
meetings you know that you're subjected
to because you may have offended this
person or that person that's not what
the college experience is supposed to be
like so parents need to be aware that
they need to work overtime unfortunately
right now
maybe fortunately in their homes and in
their communities to build backbones in
their children because the fact that we
can't sit and have a conversation
without someone crawling into a corner
and saying i need a safe space is
absolutely despicable and by the way
that's also the reason why
you have a lot of people right now who
are saying i don't want to do this when
it comes to a mandate but they succumb
because that american spirit has been
beaten down year after year after year
remember it's your family it's your body
it's your right to make those decisions
and even if there are consequences trust
me when people band together you see
what happened with the pilots they all
band together and they said you know
what this mandate doesn't work for me
and guess what change happened
so you have to you have to band together
and you have to stand for something at
the end of the day and maybe it will
cost you something listen i have spoken
my mind in places i've lost jobs i've
lost opportunities but guess what i
sleep really really well at night and i
tell people all the time stand for
something
and uh you'll sleep well at night so
yeah that's my message for the record
joe biden did say that uh it was weather
that somehow only affected southwest
flights he said it had nothing to do
with the striking pilots
deborah you've also put your butt on the
line for the things that you believe in
for people that haven't seen our full
interview um can you just talk about
what that's like just in your own
professional career because you did it
and it and it did affect the the course
of your career
right i mean i probably received the
most pushback for the things i say about
gender being critical about gender
ideology and especially you know
in terms of what's being taught in the
education system what's happening in
academia with cancer culture and
professors losing their jobs and
scientists being shunned for doing
legitimate research so i i left academia
myself because i wasn't willing to stay
quiet about the issue of gender
transitioning in children and just that
it's not back from a scientific
perspective the best course is to let
these kids wait till they get older and
make the decision about whether they
want to transition or not
um and you know the end of gender my
book came out last year and that was a
whole other wave of
harassment and things that the activists
chose to do and um but you know i feel
the same way it at the end of the day i
am proud of who i am i'm proud of my
work and i would not feel right having
to say or do do things and go along with
things that i'm not actually in
agreement with and i think more largely
with kovid i see it as a blessing in
disguise because it has shown us who
people really are in some ways i think
in terms of the authoritarianism the
controlling aspect um
i think especially with say parents who
are teaching their kids about this in
terms of bodily autonomy and the
importance of
having your own choices and your own
mind and not succumbing to peer pressure
and this is a really unfortunate way to
have to learn this lesson but i do think
it's it's a good one to have to that i
think it's really important to note that
i i do empathize with people who are
making the decision of do i keep my
blue-collar job at a factory where the
corporation that might be based on one
of the left coasts
is forcing me to get the vaccine and
like when you have to provide for your
family that's a really tough cost
benefit analysis
but i would even say to those people i
know you're not alone i get dms from
your wives and your sisters and your
kids and i think that you just ben uh
says this ben shapiro my brother from
another mother often says this he's like
just find 20
go to the friendlies in your company
over lunch break or smoke break or
whatever and say hey do you agree with
me on this because i guarantee that
there are more of you and the more that
of you that band together like we saw
with the southwest
pilots is going to have a positive
effect because the more of you there are
the more afraid their corporation will
be of losing you and they can't do that
because then it affects their bottom
line i should take a screenshot of what
my inbox looks like from the amount of
people that are reaching out to me
whatever job they might have literally
from it guys to janitors to executives
that are all trying to fight in their
own way so you're right if we can if we
can catch that 20 percent of people who
might just need to be pushed a bit more
but my last question for you guys is um
i i do sense from everything we're
talking about here that there is a mass
red pilling happening it's hard to see
in a way but in the last year and a half
like if you really think that the
government cares about you that much if
you think that the elite class cares
about you that much like you're really
sort of asleep and i think a lot of
people are questioning things that they
didn't question say two years ago and
that is good for the long-term health of
the country the society and just us as
individuals
are you guys kind of on board that crazy
positive train i'm going to try to end
this friday show with jedi i'll start
with you
yeah i think people's eyes are open
because they just they got pushed too
far i mean i think the mandates were a
big mistake a huge mistake because
people just you know people aren't
stupid by and large they have a lot of
common sense and they're saying well if
this is a virus that even if you're
vaccinated you can catch and transmit
why is this being mandated what is going
on and now they're alert to the fact
that there are politicians in power and
there are institutions in power and
social media companies in power who
really just more than anything want to
be the thought police and and the
control police and i think that that you
know the one silver lining i think
through this all is that i think a lot
of people eyes are open eyes are open
but again and i am empathetic believe me
i totally agree with what alicia said
there are people that are trying to put
food on the table and they're saying
what do i do they're between a rock and
a hard place they're up all night their
mental health is struggling i get it but
again i will say if your eyes are open
then feel compelled to do something
about it to not only say something but
to reflect it in your own life not just
for you but remember your kids learn
from you the reason one of the one of
the reasons i wrote that book to you
hardly that you held up so beautifully
dave in the beginning is because i
wanted to remind parents that kids are
watching and if you want values like
self-reliance and autonomy over your own
body and your way of thinking and
diversity of thought and all of these
things that we've talked here about
today if you want them to to receive
that and to know its importance and to
know its power you have to exemplify it
so i know it's hard sometimes but
sometimes when it's hard is when you
need to do it most because someone else
is relying on you and saying well if
they're doing it you know what i'm
happened on board too and that sense of
camaraderie can change an entire nation
and change an entire election and have
drastic positive consequences and a
ripple effect so um their eyes are open
but i think we need to see more action
it's almost like one person can change
the world who would have thunk it debra
do you see that hope do you think people
have woke up and are thinking about
things a little bit differently
i think a lot of people have woken up i
think there is still a minority of
people who are going along with this who
probably aren't going to be able to be
woken up at this point but i would say
for the people who are awake and see
what's happening
don't question your feelings about it
number one because i think that's the
worst when people feel like that that's
what really makes people go feel like
they're losing their minds because they
are being gaslit in terms of the
narrative that's happening and how
mandates are going back and forth and
people are being told all kinds of
things depending on what seems to suit a
particular political agenda so i would
say however you feel is legitimate and
don't question that don't feel that you
have to go along with what's being
presented more broadly and i would also
say going to the back to the mental
health aspect if you can even find one
other person say at work or in your
social circles with whom you agree or
you don't have to agree but with whom
you can have honest conversations about
how you feel that's going to do so much
in terms of just helping you cope to get
through this process i mean i feel very
lucky i have very supportive people in
my life i can't imagine what it's like
for people who have to go to work or are
surrounded by people in in their social
sphere when they can't actually say how
they feel or that they're questioning
any of this without fear that they're
going to be shunned or that people are
going to think that they've lost their
minds
alicia as one of the people in my social
circles in this crazy town
bring us home give us some hope
i went to four different businesses
yesterday and was only asked to put on a
mask when a one karen complained to the
sales clerk about me as i was making a
return i will not name the store but
most of the time when i walk around los
angeles especially when i have my three
adorable girls other people see me they
give me a thumbs up they give me a
little head nod and they take off their
mask little old ladies who are double
masked take off their mask and start to
talk to my girls and look at them in the
eye one woman even a couple weeks ago
looked at me with tears in her eyes and
was like this is the first child's face
i've seen in six months your girls are
beautiful thank you for letting like
thank you for sharing them with the
world so one person can make a
difference and don't underestimate that
ladies i thank you for fighting
alongside of me have a great weekend and
i'm gonna i'm gonna finish up solo here
i'm gonna try to keep the good vibes
going for just a moment or two but thank
you guys uh thanks
to your book down below well we'll link
to
deborah you've got a book too we're
going to link to that
wait do you have a book
you should have a book you should have a
book
there's a parenting book in there
somewhere all right you got to get a
book i'll send you my agent okay thank
you guys have a great weekend
all right everybody i i hope you enjoyed
that i think i fared well with three
females according to uh the google
definition of female i don't want to get
banned from uh youtube by the way we
actually believe it or not as far as i
know you know yesterday a lot of you
were commenting my god he's going to be
demonetized and deleted after all of the
things that i said yesterday as far as i
know we did not get demonetized but i
was informed this morning that
apparently on a whole host of youtube
channels uh people are getting deleted
banned demonetized the whole slew of
words that they can do to you and things
that they can do if you say let's go
brandon so i just want to say that i'm
not saying let's go brandon i'm just
curious if i'm allowed to say let's go
brandon and like what that would do if a
guy like me was to say let's go brandon
on a show like this of course i'm not
outright saying it i'm just questioning
what the youtube policy is on let's go
brandon you know we can google let's go
brandon and maybe we could google you
know find out more about this brandon
fella and what he's doing um but you
know of course i'm not just sitting here
like let's go brandon you know it
obviously that's not something that i
would say let's go brandon i'm just
saying am i allowed to say let's go
brandon because it's an interesting
thing that somebody might say you know
what i mean i have a friend my friend
from eighth grade brandon it's like
great guy let's go man you know uh so uh
look you know a lot of the main shows
that you guys watch are brought to you
by pfizer and i just want to say i'm
dave rubin this has been the reuben
report brought to you by brandon
you